belegen in dieser aktuellen stunde ist
ist tatsächlich aktueller als gedacht
bei beantragung dadurch dass die
bundesregierung der bundesminister heute
morgen die alarmstufe gas die zweite von
drei stufen ausgelöst hat und es ist
auch grundsätzlich richtig das zu tun
wenn die lage nach einschätzung der
bundesregierung so ist dass das
notwendig ist
und es ist auch tatsächlich so dass die
lage nicht nur jetzt bereits eine ernste
ist mit den drosselung der
gaslieferungen aus russland wie sie
gesehen haben sondern noch richtig ernst
werden kann denn in allen szenarien der
bundesnetzagentur für die nächsten
monate selbst wenn es bei den 40 prozent
bliebe die aktuell noch durch nord
stream 1 durch die pipeline kommen in
allen szenarien bei aktueller
lieferungen aus russland hätten wir
spätestens im februar nicht genug gas um
die deutsche wirtschaft und die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu versorgen die
lage ist also ernster als sie sich
manchmal noch in manchen debatten
widerspiegelt und deswegen herr minister
können wir auch sagen dass sie
grundsätzlich bei dem was in dieser
ernsten lage notwendig ist zu tun unsere
unterstützung haben bei dieser
unterstützung haben wir aber eben auch
fragen wir haben zum beispiel die frage
warum sie auch selbst noch vor sechs
wochen gesagt haben wir sind auf alles
vorbereitet was putin tun könnte was
muss denn russland tun könnte und nun
plötzlich etwas wochenende neue
strategie papiere neue meldungen und
dann über nacht heute morgen die
alarmanlage
die verkündet wird wir haben natürlich
schon die frage was ist passiert
zwischen wir sind gut vorbereitet auf
alles was putin tun könnte bis zu diesem
plötzlichen dieser plötzlichen wendungen
heute morgen die sich auch gestern in
der ausschuss debatte so nicht
abgezeichnet hat wir haben die frage
wir haben die frage warum die
kohlekraftwerke die sie richtigerweise
jetzt stärker nutzen wollen in ihrem
gesetzentwurf der dem deutschen
bundestag vorliegt steht übrigens noch
der erste november ab dem möglicherweise
die kohlekraftwerke genutzt werden
können ich habe verstanden dass das
jetzt früher schon ab juli möglich
werden soll was wir richtig finden aber
die frage ist natürlich warum wir das
eigentlich nicht schon seit märz gemacht
haben als wir das hier im märz in der
diskussion im deutschen bundestag
gefordert haben gab es zum teil noch
gelächter in einigen wein hier über
diese maßnahme sie ist notwendig jetzt
die gaskraftwerke zu entlasten um die
gasspeicher zu füllen hätten wir das im
märz bereits begonnen wären sie
möglicherweise heute schon voller es ist
die frage
frauen wenig früher anreize zum sparen
auch gesetzt haben statt debatten über
fairen per gesetz zu führen anreize für
die verbraucher es gibt vorschläge über
den energie gutschein anreize für die
industrie auch dort mit einem
marktmechanismus tatsächlich denjenigen
zu belohnen anzureizen der gas einspart
die instrumente sind richtig aber die
frage ist natürlich warum nicht schon
als wir sie diskutiert haben im märz und
ja wir haben auch die frage wenn die
lage so ernst ist und sie ist nach allem
was wir sehen
ernst auch ernster als es die debatte
bis hierhin teilweise in der
öffentlichkeit widerspiegelt jedenfalls
aus unserer einschätzung
dann ist es auch notwendig alle optionen
in den blick zu nehmen in einer solchen
ernsten lage wo stand jetzt
jedenfalls auch nach den szenarien der
netzagentur wie im laufe des winters in
einen tatsächlichen mangel hinein kommen
muss man alle optionen nutzen und dazu
gehören dann neben den kohlekraftwerken
auch zumindest mal im streck betrieb
wir reden müssen ja nicht gleich über
fünf oder sieben jahre reden auch die
kernkraftwerke warum schließen sie eine
solche aktion kategorisch aus in einer
schwierigen lage
heute morgen während sie die alarmanlage
ausrufen schließt ihr kollege trittin
aus dass wir in der nordsee 60
milliarden kubikmeter erdgas fördern als
deutschland auch das passt ja nicht
zusammen können nicht am selben tag und
wir sagen wir kommen in deutschland in
einer mangel lage dann wieder sage aber
selbst bei uns in der nordsee wollen wir
nichts dafür tun diese mangel lage zu
adressieren ja wir brauchen die
unterstützung auch anderer länder aber
ich finde dann sind wir heute
verantwortung das was in deutschland
möglich ist zu tun auch das passt nicht
zusammen nehmen sie auch diese
erdgasvorkommen bitte in den blick bei
ihren überlegungen
dazu gehört übrigens auch biogas und
biomasse auch das spielt in den
überlegungen das potenzial das da ist
das sagen die betreiber das sagen die
verbände bis jetzt keine rolle wenn die
lage so ist wie sie ist dann bitte alle
optionen in den blick nehmen und eine
letzte bitte frau präsidentin lassen sie
uns jetzt oder besser bereiten sie jetzt
und das in der diskussion mit dem
deutschen bundestag alles vor für die
mögliche dritte letzte stufe auf das sie
nie nötig werde aber wenn sie nötig
würde das sind sensibles thema darüber
zu sprechen aber muss er darüber reden
hätte das folgen schmerzhafte folgen für
die deutsche wirtschaft für die
bürgerinnen und bürger ist käme einem
schock gleich der schock wäre aber
geringer wenn es vorher einen plan das
kombinierte zum schluss akzeptiert gibt
einen plan den wir seit wochen
einfordern hier im deutschen bundestag
bitte bereiten sie auch das vor was noch
kommen kann mit einem plan der
transparent und nachvollziehbar ist es
ist gut dass sich jetzt hier sind und
dass dem deutschen bundestag dazu nehmen
jens spahn der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
unionsfraktionen mit unterstützung aber
einige fragen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister denen sie auf
der regierungsbank auch sie sehen der
wird gleich auch noch sprechen in dieser
aktuellen stunde wahrscheinlich noch mit
einigen antworten dann also die
bundesregierung hat die zweite stufe
ausgerufen den notfallmaßnahmen die
alarmstufe im märz hatte robert habeck
bereits die frühwarn stufe ausgewiesen
verzichtet hat die bundesregierung
übrigens die erst mal auf einen
entscheidenden schritt der unternehmen
und verbrauchern sofortige drastische
preiserhöhungen beim erdgas beschert
hätte das wäre nämlich theoretisch
möglich mit dieser alarmstufe nina
scheer für die spd ist es eine
besorgniserregende situation in der wir
stecken mit der ausrufung des der
alarmstufe des notfallplans gas das ist
ja die zweite stufe von 3 ist in der tat
das sagt ja auch der notfallplan eine
situation gegeben in denen maßnahmen
ergriffen werden müssen um eben einer
versorgungsnotlage zu entgehen um einen
versorgungsengpass zu entgehen es sind
auch schon vorher vorkehrungen getroffen
worden und es ist auch klar dass mit
denen schon bescheid bereits
beschlossenen maßnahmen alles daran
gesetzt wird eine mangel lage
auszuschließen an dieser stelle möchte
ich auch noch mal kurz erwähnen was wir
alles in den letzten monaten schon auf
den weg gebracht habe um genau das zu
ermöglichen dass ihnen keine
versorgungsmangel lage eintritt wir
haben ein gasspeicher gesetz
verabschiedet was eben dafür sorgt dass
die füllstände rechtzeitig zum winter
auch wirklich so sind dass nicht jeder
das eintritt wie es zu jahresanfang war
dass sie eben nicht gefüllt waren das
haben wir gesetzlich geregelt dass das
nicht wieder passiert und wir sind doch
bisher auf einem guten weg innerhalb von
30 tagen von jetzt ausgerechnet hätte
man erreichen können die speicher
aufzufüllen weil am tag an einem tag so
viel gefüllt war wurde dass man zuletzt
das hätte erreichen können aber offenbar
war genau das auch ein element was von
russischer seite sehr genau beobachtet
wurde und man kann schon wenn man die
gesamtlage beobachtet erkennen dass
jetzt auch die verfügbarkeit von energie
in deutschland von ausreichendem gas
anhand der vorsorge maßnahmen die wir
getroffen haben von russland jetzt
kontaktiert wird um eben tatsächlich es
als strategisches politisches
erpressungs instrument einzusetzen um
uns auch politisch in die knie zu
zwingen das ist tatsächlich das ansinnen
was man dahinter entdecken kann das gas
flüsse zurück gedreht werden dass sie
gedrosselt werden weil es korrespondiert
in der tat mit den
ermöglichen von mehr gas einspeicherung
wie wir es in den letzten wochen
verstärkt angeschoben haben aber darauf
gilt es geschickt und auch besonnen zu
reagieren weil wir wissen alle dass wir
noch eine hohe abhängigkeit haben und
dass wir auch versuchen müssen diese
situation nicht unsererseits zu
gefährden denn die gas flüsse haben nun
mal an sich dass man nicht einfach nur
mengen kalkulieren muss sondern auch in
flüssen durch flüssen und die versorgung
eben nur dann überall in deutschland
gewährleistet ist wenn es eben mit den
flüssen stimmt und da ist es nicht nur
ein mengenproblem
insofern das war der eine bereich wir
haben zum zweiten auch ein lg gesetz
verabschiedet womit wir ermöglichen das
eben diversifiziert werden kann dass wir
eben weg kommen können von den import
abhängigkeiten von russischem erdgas und
eben andere bezugsquellen verstärkt mit
anlandung an den deutschen küsten häfen
ermöglichen können auch das ist
geschehen wir haben eine energie
sicherungs gesetz verabschiedet was eben
auch vorsieht wie geht man damit um wenn
dann noch einmal eine menge lage
eintritt wie kann man versorger auch in
die richtung in die in die situation
versetzen dass sie weiterhin versorger
sind die kann der staat eintreten wenn
daneben die versorger nicht mehr in der
lage sein sollten diese
versorgungsaufgaben zu erfüllen und zu
guter letzt sind wir jetzt und das ist
ein weiteres kapitel gerade im
parlamentarischen verfahren an der satz
kraftwerke bereitstellungs gesetz auf
den weg zu bringen was eben auch nochmal
regeln soll das in diesem ernstfall die
versorgungs prioritäten zu denen wir
auch europäisch verpflichtet sind
nämlich dass die endkunden immer
versorgt sind dass wir an dem
daseinsvorsorge auftrag in richtung
endkunden gerecht werden dass dem auch
gerecht geworden werden kann
das ist sonst ein ganzes ein ganzer
strauß von maßnahmen und insofern ist
das in verbindung mit dem riesenpaket
was wir was noch deutlich größer ist als
das gras geschildert was das deutlich
wichtigere ist in der perspektive
nämlich beschleunigt auf erneuerbare
energien umsteigen zu können das ist
jetzt wirkt heute nach zehn stunden die
begleitmusik aber es ist eigentlich der
großteil der politischen aufgaben die
wir gerade verfolgen und ja natürlich so
schnell wie möglich und in die lage
versetzen muss dass wir gar nicht mehr
von fossilen energien abhängig sind
sondern dass wir diese diese situation
überwinden das wird mit dem muster paket
und den support paket verfolgt
und insofern ist das ist eben dieser weg
hier gegangen wird ein sehr
herausfordernder aber er ist der
richtige und der falsche wäre jetzt auf
genau diese abhängigkeiten wieder
zurückzufallen wenn sie überforderung
dass das mit laufzeitverlängerungen
getan werden müssten dann verhaften wir
weiter würden wir weiter in den
teuersten energieformen verhaften dann
werden wir weiter in den abhängigkeiten
würden uns weiter behindern die
energiewende schnell voranzubringen das
wäre der falsche weg vielen dank geraten
janina hat das erwähnt der bundestag hat
ende märz ein gasspeicher gesetz
verabschiedet das die betreiber
verpflichtet dass die gasspeicher
schrittweise auf 90 zum ersten dezember
eines jahres gefüllt sein sollen im
moment sind sie zu 58 prozent gefüllt
meine damen und herren 15 grad im winter
hält man im pullover aus daran stirbt
niemand zitat ende sie meine damen und
herren von der cdu/csu sie um diese
aktuelle stunde aufgesetzt und sie
ersparen haben darüber geredet im winter
soll niemand frieren müssen aber dieses
eingangs zitat dieses unsägliche eigenes
zitat ist von ihrem cdu
landwirtschaftsminister in baden
württemberg peter hauk sie sollten sich
schämen wer hier große reden schwingt
und dann in interviews die eigene
arroganz und überheblichkeit
durchscheinen lässt der zeigt eines
ihnen geht es eben nicht um die bürger
dieses landes in geht's um reine
symbolpolitik und diese aktuelle stunde
der unionsfraktion zeigt doch
symptomatisch ein grundproblem der
deutschen politik der vergangenen jahre
dass sie alle also von der cdu bis hin
zur ampel gemeinsam zu verantworten
haben ideologisch verblendet haben sie
in nahezu allen wichtigen
politikbereichen notwendige substanz
abgebaut die nicht mehr ersetzt wurde
und wenn dann krisenzeiten kommen wird
dieses problem schonungslos offengelegt
beispiele 1 ein krieg in europa bricht
aus und ganz plötzlich fällt ihnen allen
auf dass die bundeswehr über jahre lang
vernachlässigt wurde und nicht weil
unser eigenes land verteidigen könnte
beispiel nummer zwei als corona über uns
kommt wird ihnen vom einen auf den
anderen moment bewusst dass sie das
ganze gesundheitssystem kaputt gespart
haben und nun beispiel 3 nun werden die
energievorräte zum winter hin knapp und
ganz plötzlich fällt den altparteien auf
das deutschland in ideologischer
verblendung in der energiepolitik aufs
falsche pferd gesetzt hat und die
versorgungssicherheit unseres landes
gefährdet
schon vor dem angriff schon vor dem
angriff putins auf die ukraine lag die
preissteigerung bei erdgas bei 32
prozent bei heizöl waren sogar 52 schon
2019 muss laut zahlen des statistischen
bundesamt zwei millionen menschen in
deutschland darunter insbesondere
alleinerziehende mit ihren kindern
frieren weil sich die heizkosten nicht
mehr leisten konnten der drohende kälte
wind und diese enormen preis explosionen
die fallen also nicht vom himmel sondern
das ist die folge ihrer verfehlten
energiepolitik meine damen und herren
haben aber ich bin ja froh versuchen wir
immer das positive zu sehen ich bin ja
froh dass die unions fraktion und auch
bundesfinanzminister lindner jetzt in
der krise offensichtlich panisch nach
lösungen suchen und deshalb in unserer
auf die wahlprogramme rein geschaut
haben denn ganz plötzlich und wir uns
gerade eben hier vom pult offen herr
sparen gehört ganz plötzlich werden die
rufe nach einer kernforderung unserer
bürger partei laut wir brauchen eine
rückkehr zur sicheren und sauberen
kernenergie um versorgungssicherheit und
vor allem bezahlbare energie zu
gewährleisten damit anfangen was wir
schon jahrelang predigen fordert nun
also auch die unionsfraktion im
deutschen bundestag wieder mal zeigt
sich wie als afx die wir haben die
besseren ideen für deutschland und wir
wirklich meine damen und herren in
puncto themensetzung haben sie sich
jetzt also ja schon erfolgreich bei uns
bedient das in ordnung aber jetzt kommt
ja der entscheidende punkt wort und tat
sollten bei guten politikern
übereinstimmen meine damen und herren
und wie sieht es bei der cdu aus china
wort zu mit taten über ein lieber
ersparen sie haben gerade gefordert wir
müssen wieder zurück zur kernenergie
leider eine ich mich vielleicht falsch
das war doch so dass sie von den grünen
getrieben 2011 dafür gesorgt haben dass
deutschland völlig überstürzt aus der
kernenergie aussteigt und war es nicht
so dass sie sogar noch im april 2022
also vor wenigen wochen hier im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
zusammen mit den vertretern der ampel
parteien unseren afg antrag zur
verlängerung der kernkraft werde zur
laufzeitverlängerung einstimmig
abgelehnt haben meine damen und herren
also entweder leiden sie an demenz oder
sie versuchen ihr böswillig unsere
bürger da draußen für blöd zu verkaufen
was daran schlimmer ist kann ich ihnen
nicht sagen aber eins bleibt klar die
cdu csu ist sicher keine alternative zur
ampel politik sondern ein konservativ
lackierter wurmfortsatz rot-grüner
politik meine damen und herren und ganz
im gegensatz zu ihnen stehen wir als fc
zu unserem wort und haben schon in
unserem grundsatzprogramm die
kernenergie als baustein eines breiten
energiemixes fest verankert während sie
damals noch mit ihren grünen freunden
vom nächsten windpark geträumt haben
aber unsere bürger brauchen jetzt
dringend eine sichere und vor allem eine
bezahlbare energieversorgung damit sie
im winter nicht frieren müssen deswegen
sehen wir mal über die vergangenheit
hinweg und wenn union und fdp jetzt
unserer meinung sind dann bieten wir
gerne unsere unterstützung an eine
mehrheit wäre ja da meine damen und
herren also hören sie auf zu reden und
handeln sie endlich verlängern sie die
laufzeit der verbliebenen kernkraftwerke
investieren sie endlich in die forschung
und weiterentwicklung so dass auch
langfristig neue werke gebaut werden
können und entlasten sie unsere bürger
durch steuersenkungen zum beispiel im
bereich der co2 steuer sorgen sie also
dafür dass das geld unserer fleißigen
bürger hier in deutschland bleibt und
nicht überall auf der welt verschleudert
wird werden sie endlich ihrer
verantwortung gerecht denn in diesem
winter soll kein deutscher frieren
müssen ich danke ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
sebastian münzenmaier der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der afg fraktion und jetzt hören wir den
bundeswirtschaftsminister
robert habeck der heute morgen ja schon
gesagt hat das ist von nun an ein
knappes gut in deutschland und hat die
alarmstufe ausgerufen die zweite stufe
präsidentin viele danken vielen dank
starke worte ideologische verblendung
vielleicht soviel vorneweg einer partei
von einer partei die sich weiter in die
abhängigkeit von putins gas treiben
lassen will wie die sanktionen aufheben
will jedem grunde will dass die ukraine
sich nicht so anstellen sollte natürlich
tut ihnen unterwerfen soll muss man
schon unterstellen dass man sehr blind
sein muss um anderen ideologische
verblendung vor bewerten diese partei
ist nicht und für deutschland sie ist
gut für putin ist gut für punkt
uns selber und der eigenen ideologischen
windheim verhaftet
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
bin nicht der meinung dass diese debatte
symbolpolitik ist im gegenteil man muss
die cdu dankbar sein dass wir heute
diese gelegenheit zur aussprache haben
sie ist genau angemessen wir müssen uns
darüber austauschen parlamentarisch wie
in der gesellschaft was eigentlich
gerade passiert und diese aktuelle
stunde kann dazu einen beitrag leisten
dass wir diese debatte führen allerdings
sollte auch als gemeinsame debatte
verstanden werden im streit um die
besten argumente und lieber jens spahn
[Musik]
was ist passiert haben sie gefragt nun
passiert ist dass putin das gemacht hat
wo vor einige und ich würde für mich
informieren auch ich immer gewarnt haben
dass er den gashahn noch nicht komplett
abgedreht hat aber doch schrittweise
reduziert um die preise in deutschland
hoch zu halten dem druck auf die
bevölkerung zu erhöhen und dieses land
zu spalten und den nährboden für seine
freunde ganz rechts im rechten
populismus spektrum zu bereiten ich will
aber auch erinnern
ich würde mich wirklich und hatte auch
mit dem verlegen auf der landesebene als
austausch gemeinsame austausch debatte
zu führen dass ihr fraktionsvorsitzender
noch nicht vor wenigen wochen genau das
gefordert hat bevor sie jetzt fragen
nämlich eine sofortige sagt ein fertiges
um sambo von gas einzuführen was
passiert frage ich mich bei der union
gab es so wenig kenntnisse um die
energieversorgung oder energiesicherheit
in deutschland und bei den konkreten
kunden
bei den konkreten punkten will ich ihnen
jahren folgen beziehungsweise da wo wir
noch nicht selber gut genug arbeiten die
punkte auch übernehmen aber die
selbstherrlichkeit sich hierhin zu
setzen oder hinzustellen und zu sagen
wie konntet ihr nur so langsam sein von
einer fatalen die über jahre ja
jahrzehnte die abhängigkeit von
deutschland fand einem und das darf man
wohl schon sagen nach 2014 und dem
angriff auf die ukraine von einem
mindestens zwielichtigen herrscher immer
größer gemacht hat und das was uns
wirklich helfen würde die unabhängigkeit
durch den ausbau von erneuerbaren
energien und energieeffizienz
systematisch abgewürgt hat sich anhören
zulassen dass wir uns nicht genau gut
genug vorbereitet haben dass es schon
eine ziemliche verdrehung der
wirklichkeit wir sind
wir sind
vorbereitet so gut man ist eben machen
kann wenn man keine datengrundlage für
die bsa vorfindet wenn man keine gesetze
vorfindet die in irgendeiner form gehabt
nur politische handlungsmöglichkeiten
erstellen wir haben uns darauf
vorbereitet und das was sie jetzt staunt
bewundern die vorschläge aus dem
wochenende und das ausrufen der
alarmstufe ist exakt das ergebnis dieser
vorbereitung dass wir uns über wochen
und monate schritt für schritt mit dem
szenario auseinandergesetzt haben und
jetzt konkrete vorschläge und die gelder
bereitstellen können auf diese situation
zu reagieren
ja
es ist ärgerlich dass wir diesen das
auktions mechanismus noch nicht jetzt
haben aber wo kommt der ärger denn her
das ist neu datengrundlage dafür gab wo
dann überhaupt gasspeicher sind es die
bsa und der holding europe die jetzt in
windeseile ein digitales system
erstellen müssen dann überhaupt zu
verstehen wo die gasmengen deutschland
verbraucht werden und wie sie
zusammenhängen klar der ist super alles
schon fertig zu haben war aber nicht nur
höher leerer schreibtisch jetzt sind wir
schneller als die digitalisierung der
gesundheitsämter und wer hatte die noch
eigentlich zu verantworten sehr geehrte
damen und herren dass wir dass wir die
voraussetzung für
hier setzte
geschaffen haben die jetzt in der
alarmstufe gegebenenfalls aktiviert
werden können und ich sage können in die
alarmstufe ist die voraussetzung für das
was jetzt im parlamentarischen raum ist
nun nicht dass kohle rein gas raus
gesetzt das dann ja am 8 07 und
verabschiedet ist ist gebunden an die
arabischen für ist zeichen guter
vorbereitung dass wir ein
marktmechanismus etablieren können und
in der gas in der nur allah mission für
einsetzen können ist zeiten bis zeichen
guter vorbereitung und das hier auch ein
preismechanismus einsetzen können über
das energie sicherungs gesetz 24 ist
zeichen guter vorbereitung aber es ist
kein spiel und deswegen ist die aktuelle
stunde wichtig um zu verstehen was
gerade los ist die alarmstufe auszurufen
bedarf einer analyse was eigentlich los
ist und wir müssen ein punkt überwinden
den wir alle in uns tragen es ist sommer
wir wollen eigentlich raus wir wollen
nach zwei pandemie sah man endlich mal
wieder frei sein aber der winter steht
vor der tür jetzt schon politisch steht
er vor der tür und wir müssen dieses
vorsorge paradoxon loswerden dass wir
jetzt nicht die massnahmen ergreifen
obwohl sie jetzt überhaupt noch nicht
spürbar sind die wir im winter brauchen
das ist die herausforderung und dafür
leistet ein wichtiges signal wir haben
eine glas kriselt in deutschland und wir
haben diese gaskrise in deutschland
obwohl im moment die
versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet ist
ja obwohl im moment die speicherstände
streichen steigen aber wenn es wieder
kälter wird und möglicherweise weitere
szenarien eintreffen und sie wissen
vielleicht weil sie haben schon mal
gehört dass regulär vom elften juli an
lost um 1 auf null gefahren wird um
wartungsarbeiten durchzuführen da kommt
also gar kein gas mehr durch und der
vergangenheit hat diese wartungszeit
ungefähr zehn tage gedauert diese zehn
tage können aber so wie die plage
aussehen natürlich auch länger dauern
also werden sich die dinge verschärfen
dann rutschen denn ein szenario ein wo
wir nicht genug gas haben um über den
winter zu kommen deswegen ist jede
kraftanstrengung jetzt notwendig das gas
das wir einsparen können einzusparen und
natürlich sind das schmerzhafte
entscheidung und wo sie immer mit atom
kommen ich meinen einmal kurz noch mal
klarstellen wir brauchen ja gas werden
müssen heizen und das tun wir ja nicht
mit atomkraftwerken und die industrie
aber auch die wärme und die punkte ja ja
die gedanken die privaten sind ja schon
mehrfach gefühlt wenn sie wollen die ich
noch mal gleich kurz darauf ein aber der
punkt ist der punkt ist jetzt habe ich
einen kollegen im ausschuss schon
erklärt aber man muss also viel reden
und sie merken es trotzdem nicht und
verstehen es trotzdem nicht machen auch
anstrengend
die aufgabe ist natürlich dass wir jetzt
durch höhere co2 emissionen durch das
verleihen von kohlekraftwerken diese co2
emission
später wieder einsparen und das ist das
interessante was gerade in deutschland
passiert wir haben eine oberfläche auf
die starke schaut wird ln sie gas
kohlekraftwerke diese oberfläche steht
unter druck sie ist zerkratzt sie ist
verbeult und da gibt es keine guten
entscheidungen und niemand sollte sich
dafür rühl schwierige entscheidungen zu
treten zu treffen oder gut zu finden
aber unterhalb der oberfläche passiert
eigentlich gerade das entscheidende in
diesem land wir haben eine hohe dynamik
die wiederkäuer bar energien ausbauen
will wir haben eine hohe bereitschaft
der unternehmen zu investieren und zwar
eine klimaneutrale technologie die
anträge wasserstoff zu machen die
infrastruktur auszubauen
sie übersteigen die das fördervolumen
wir haben im moment eine hohe nachfrage
nach gebäudesanierung nach energetischer
gebäudesanierung jeder von uns hat sich
hier hingestellt und gesagt wir sind
viel zu langsam der schlafende riese
gebäudesanierung 1 prozent oder weniger
pro jahr wir brauchen noch 100 tage bis
wir fertig sind auf einmal explodiert
ist geradezu und wir haben zu wenig
handwerker für die gebäudesanierung das
passiert gerade in deutschland und ist
gerade besonders ist unter der
oberfläche es gibt rote die
unentschlossenheit der mensch wir haben
hohe inflation die menschen leiden
darunter die unternehmen leiden darunter
und trotzdem gibt es eine bereitschaft
hier zusammen zu stehen die notwendigen
dinge gemeinsam und das ist unsere
aufgabe müssen wir gemeinsam sondern
schwer die last und zu verteilen zu
tragen weil wir wissen dass dieser
angriff einen angriff auf die
freiheitliche demokratische grundordnung
ist und das wird diesen angriff
zurückweisen müssen mit allem was wir
haben vielen dank
der bundeswirtschaftsminister hier
nochmal mit seinen erklärungen heute hat
er die alarmstufe im notfallplan gas
aktiviert das ist übrigens auch die
voraussetzung für die umsetzung der
pläne der bundesregierung verstärkt
kohlekraftwerke ans netz zu holen um den
gasverbrauch im stromsektor zu
reduzieren da gibt es gerade ein
gesetzgebungsverfahren das soll noch vor
der sommerpause den bundestag passieren
zu einem ersatzkraftwerke breit haltungs
gesetz
draußen ist ein heißer junitag die
sommerferien stehen bevor und viele
sehen sich nach urlaub ohne chor ohne
einschränkungen der grausam ukraine
krieg scheint zu weit weg wieder winter
aber putins krieg trifft auch uns die
gasversorgung ist nicht mehr sicher auch
ohne gas embargo seit letzter woche
liefert russland weniger gas als
vereinbart ins feind ohne konsequente
maßnahmen droht deutschland und europa
ein zusammenbruch der gasversorgung im
winter der bundestag hat bereits viel
auf den weg gebracht um gasversorgung
energiesicherheit zu gewährleisten
aber es reicht nicht wir brauchen
weitere schritte um die energie und
wärmeversorgung für haushalte handwerk
und industrie zu garantieren und energie
muss bezahlbar bleiben und trotzdem
dürfen wir den klimaschutz nicht
vergessen
jetzt
jetzt genau auf die gestrige der union
selbst teile der fdp atomkraft wäre eine
lösung
als techniker glaube ich nicht ich halte
mich an fangen und sie sprechen klar
gegen die atomkraft
frankreich hat 56 atommeiler über die
hälfte ist seit monaten außer betrieb
die restlichen akw können keine volle
leistung liefern weil wegen der dürre in
frankreich kühlwasser fehlt ohne massive
stromlieferung aus deutschland und
anderen eu-staaten gebe es längst ein
blick auf
atomkraft bringt keine
versorgungssicherheit selbst bei
ausblenden der supergau gefahren
eine kilowattstunde aus neuen
atomkraftwerken hat herstellkosten von
zwölf cent strom aus einem windrad
weniger als sechs sind auch preislich
ist atomkraft keine alternative
seit märz
ostdeutschland gas zu sparen um die
speicher für den kommenden winter zu
füllen und seit monaten müssen deutsche
gas kraftwerke laufen um frankreich vor
dem blackout zu retten es ist nicht
absehbar wann in frankreich wieder
ausreichend atomenergie hergestellt wird
wir müssen aber gas sparen und daher
werden jetzt alte kohlekraftwerke
reaktiviert das ist schlecht fürs klima
und auch deshalb müssen wir energie
einsparen wo immer es geht
es sind noch nicht alle möglichkeiten
ausgeschöpft
beispiele in lübeck steht ein großer
speicher für fernwärme in schleswig
holstein gibt es oft zu viel windstrom
dann stehen die windräder
logisch ist es mit überschüssigen
windstrom den wärmespeicher zu füllen
statt mit erdgas zu heizen
liebe koalition
ändern sie sofort netzentgelt
problematik damit lübeck mit
überschussstrom heizen kann windräder
nicht ungenutzt stehen gas gespart wird
aber lübeck nicht wie derzeit
draufzahlen muss
haben union und fdp den einspeise bonus
für biomethan gestrichen es ist zeit
diesen fehler zu korrigieren
und ich weiß es ist kein populärer
vorschlag ladenöffnungszeit am sonntag
vorübergehend abzuschaffen und nachts
geschäfte zu schließen doch all diese
vorschläge verursachen kleine bühne im
vergleich zu den problemen in kalten
wohnungen im winter
kolleginnen und kollegen besonders in
krisenzeiten muss der staat
handlungsfähig seien der schutz der
menschen vor explodierenden
energiekosten ist unverzichtbar er
kostet milliarden aber das geld darf
nicht in die profite von spekulanten
spekulanten fließen und deshalb fordert
die linke eine staatliche energiepreis
aussieht
deshalb müssen krisen und
kriegsgewinnler übersteuern wieder
einkassiert werden wir brauchen das geld
zum ausgleich der hohen energiekosten
und zum ausgleich wer die linke
monatlich 125 euro für single-haushalte
175 euro für zwei personen haushalte und
450 euro für jedes weitere
haushaltsmitglied bereitstellen
damit deutschland zukünftig nicht erneut
durch energieabhängigkeit ob festwirt
und gut durch kommende winter kommt
braucht es mehr staatlichen einfluss im
energiesektor gestärkte stadtwerke und
energie genossenschaften
die übertragungsnetze gehören in
staatlicher hand wir brauchen einen
masterplan energie speicher und
natürlich deutlich mehr wind- und
solarenergie vielen dank
als schlinkert war das für die linke der
sprecher für energie und klimaschutz
sohn jetzt würden wir hier in dieser
aktuellen stunde beantragt von der
unionsfraktion den nächsten redner für
die liberalen spricht der lukas kohler
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ich glaube allen ist
bewusst dass die lage ernst ist und die
aktuelle stunde die union ist auch an
der richtigen stelle eingesetzt es ist
tatsächlich notwendig darüber zu
sprechen und insbesondere in einer sich
weiter zuspitzenden situation wenn man
sich die szenarien der bundesnetzagentur
anguckt dann laufen wir in
mit pech dramatische situation ich
glaube das kann man das muss man auch so
ernst erwähnen bei uns das allen klemmt
ich glaube ist es 100 prozent richtig
dass wir jetzt darüber nachdenken jetzt
handeln jetzt gesetze schaffen jetzt
miteinander darüber sprechen was ist
alles zu tun was ich glaube diese
regierung hat in den letzten wochen
monaten und jahren hätte ich gerne
gesagt aber das hat ja leider nicht den
letzten wochen und monaten seit anfang
des jahres hat anfang dieser krise viele
dinge vorgelegt und wir als parlament
haben in schnellen verfahren und da auch
noch mal danke auch insbesondere an die
union die das sehr sehr oft und
richtigerweise unterstützt wenn es um
verantwortung in diesem land gibt hat
gehandelt
wir haben schon viel getan aber wir
laufen in eine situation und in gefahr
in der ist nicht sicher ist ob das alles
reicht was wir tun und wir müssen jetzt
ihr müssen lieber über alle optionen
nachdenken wie wir weitermachen wie wir
über alle optionen nachrichten bereit
und zwar nicht nur darüber wie wir zum
beispiel den biomethan einsatz
verbessern ich glaube das kann eine
quelle sein in der wir viel erreichen
ich glaube wir müssen auch darüber
nachdenken wie wir jetzt einsparen da
muss man sagen die aktuellen
preissignale im gasbereich insbesondere
in der industrie setzen ja schon das
signal das wir einsparen kein
unternehmen sagt mensch ich verfahre
aktuell gerne gas weil das so teuer ist
und deswegen läuft da ja auch schon viel
und wir haben viele kluge menschen wir
haben tolle tüftler ingenieure in
deutschland die glaube ich jeden tag
daran arbeiten wie können wir auch für
den winter auch für die hoffentlich zu
vermeidende situation in der wir in die
dritte stufe gehen müssten und dann
wirklich unternehmen kein gas mehr
bequem
dass wir das verhindern da denken viele
leute darüber nach nicht nur wir hier im
bundestag nicht nur der regulator
sondern ich glaube und das müssen wir
uns immer wieder bewusst machen es ist
an der zeit dass die menschen die das
können auch machen wir müssen sie dabei
unterstützen da gibt es genug
regulatorischen die wir abschaffen
wollen ich sag jetzt mal im solarbereich
relativ einfach die frage der
netzanschluss zertifikate das klingt
total absurd ist ein kleines thema
verhindert aber dass gerade große mengen
an solaranlagen ans netz gehen wir
arbeiten daran dass das schnellstmöglich
abgeschafft sind ganz konkreter punkt
und manchmal der teufel und insbesondere
bei der gesetzeslage die wir so in
deutschland haben liegt der teufel sehr
oft in den details in den fragen die wir
ändern müssen und darauf müssen wir uns
konzentrieren
wir müssen aber lieber reift habe gesagt
über alle dienen und optionen nachdenken
und ich glaube und wir wünschen uns dass
alle nicht wir wünschen uns alle nicht
dass wir darüber nachdenken müssen wie
wir in den nächsten wochen und monaten
energie produzieren können ohne dabei
das zu nutzen und natürlich gibt es
tolle chancen die wir haben es gibt
tolle möglichkeiten und wir müssen und
wir sollen und wir werden darauf setzen
dass wir die freiheit energien ausbauen
wir werden auch darauf setzen und ich
bin mir auch sicher dass die aktuelle
situation zum beispiel den kohleausstieg
invega 23.30 vollziehen wollen nicht in
frage stellt ich weiß auch dass die
aktuellen mehr verstromung von kohle
nicht dazu führen wird dass wir mehr co2
ausstoßen bei der europäische
emissionshandel das zum glück verhindert
weil wir da so ein gutes instrument
haben dass klimaschutz sicherstellt und
klar ist aber auch dass wir über alle
optionen nachdenken müssen und ja wir
haben über kosten gesprochen und ja ich
habe mich hier schon oft genug
hingestellt und gesagt die atomenergie
meine damen und herren ist keine
zukunftsfähige energie weil sie einfach
zu teuer ist und weil sie andere
probleme zumindest die alten meiler wir
sehen das im moment in frankreich welche
probleme es gibt aber dass wir in einer
situation in der wir jetzt sind nicht
weiter darüber nachdenken was wir tun
können um dinge einzusparen meine damen
und herren ich glaube das können wir uns
nicht erlauben und das tut uns weh und
es ist nicht schön wir machen das nicht
gerne aber dass wir darüber nachdenken
diskutieren wie schaffen wir es über den
winter zu kommen ich glaube vor dieser
herausforderung stehen wir und deswegen
meiner meinung nach müssen wir das auch
weiter tun und zwar
gesamtgesellschaftlich es ist ja ein
problem für alle menschen in deutschland
wenn wir nicht genügend gas haben es ist
für alle menschen ein problem und wir
müssen ist so sinnvoll andienten wir
können wir müssen mit den optionen die
wir haben so gut wie möglich darüber
nachdenken und darüber sprechen was wir
tun um diese situation herr zu werden
ich bin mir aber sicher ich bin mir aber
absolut sicher dass wir das gemeinsam
hinkriegen weil ich weiß wie viele dinge
gut in dieser wunderbaren koalition
funktionieren und das ist gut und ich
freue mich dass ich auch die artez
beruhigen konnte vielen dank
etwas kühler war das filet liberalen er
hat auch noch mal die dritte
eskalationsstufe angesprochen dieses
theoretisch gibt ja mozart lang gas für
die notfall stufe müsste dann das ganze
kabinett zustimmen und die greift in
einer gas mangel lage das heißt wenn er
wenn der markt nicht mehr in der lage
wäre ein ausgleich zwischen nachfrage
und geringem angebot zu schaffen dann
teilt die bundesnetzagentur mit wer noch
gas bekommt
gegen die ukraine führt er zeigt uns
jeden tag mehr notwendig es ist dass wir
unabhängig werden so schnell wie möglich
von russischen energielieferungen weil
es unerträglich ist dass wir geld nach
russland gegen geben und zumindest
indirekt diese kriegsmaschinerie
finanzieren und wir müssen damit rechnen
dass putin den gashahn zudreht zur
hälfte ist er bereits zugedreht und
möglicherweise wird er ganz zugedreht
und das könnte bei uns im winter
verheerende auswirkungen haben wenn
gasmengen fehlen sollten wenn preise
durch die decke gehen aber wie stark die
auswirkungen tatsächlich sein werden das
hängt eben auch maßgeblich davon ab
inwieweit die regierung in dieser lage
richtig agiert seit kriegsbeginn
sagen wir alle möglichkeiten um
russisches gas bei uns zu ersetzen
müssen auf den tisch sie müssen ehrlich
bewertet werden und wir brauchen einen
ausstiegsfahrplan
das hat der deutsche bundestag übrigens
hier im april mit großer mehrheit mit
ganz großer mehrheit beschlossen einen
plan der aufzeigt wie können wir
gaslieferungen kompensieren durch welche
konkreten maßnahmen in welchen
zeitlichen schritten zu welchen kosten
aber ich frage sie herr minister habe so
ist dieser fahrplan er liegt uns nicht
vor es ist jetzt vier monate seit
kriegsbeginn sie ignorieren offenkundig
diesem bundestagsbeschluss nicht fordere
sie auf legen sie einen solchen
ausstiegsfahrplan vor
der minister habe sie haben angekündigt
weniger gas zu strom zur verstromung
einzusetzen ja das ist richtig das ist
sogar notwendig dass wir gasmengen
einsprachen können zusätzlich ein
speichern das unterstützen wir aber auch
hier frage ich warum erst jetzt am 18
märz hat die leopoldina einen weg
aufgezeigt als sofortmaßnahme wie man
gasmengen einsparen kann bei der
verstromung wenige tage danach eine
studie der energiewirtschaft das gleiche
thema ich habe die bundesregierung im
märz gefragt welche maßnahmen werden in
dieser hinsicht ergriffen die antwort
der bundesregierung wir prüfen ich habe
im april die gleiche frage gestellt
antwort bundesregierung wir analysieren
wir haben es in der zwischenzeit im
ausschuss im bundestag immer wieder
thematisiert es ist nichts passiert
daher ist die frage mehr als berechtigt
warum erst jetzt
hätte in regierung an dieser stelle
früher gehandelt wir könnten heute
relevante mengen an erdgas mehr in den
speichern haben wir wären besser
vorbereitet auf den nächsten winter als
es tatsächlich der fall ist und herr
minister ich sage ihnen ich habe respekt
vor ihrer kommunikationsleistung in
diesen wochen nicht meine ist genauso
wie ich es sage aber das tatsächliche
regierungshandeln es hinkt hinterher
meine damen und herren
weniger strom oder weniger gas für die
verstromung
heißt mehr strom aus kohle im moment das
heißt mehr co2 das ist zunächst aus
klimaschutzgründen
nachteilig umso mehr müssen wir uns an
anderer stelle anstrengen um beim
klimaschutz noch schneller zu werden
noch besser voranzukommen daher ist es
richtig und auch das unterstützen wir
mehr tempo beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wasserstoff strategie
konsequent umsetzen aber warum nutzen
sie denn zb nicht kurzfristig die
vorhandenen potenziale im bereich der
biomasse das ist ebenfalls seit märz
thema und warum passiert nicht mehr beim
thema energie einsparen auch hier könnte
man konsequenter vorangehen und warum
haben sie sich dagegen entschieden die
drei kernkraftwerke die noch am netz hin
und die am 31.12 abgeschaltet werden
sollen einen tick länger laufen zu
lassen ich habe zweifel dass es offen
und ehrlich geprüft wurde und herr
minister sie haben selbst gestern im
ausschuss gesagt es war eine politische
entscheidung es war eine politische
entscheidung die drei kernkraftwerke
nicht etwas länger laufen zu lassen
natürlich gibt es da hörten wenn man es
tun würde das ist klar aber diese hörten
sie wären überwindbar gewesen und ich
sage wo ein wille ist ist auch ein weg
aber der wille war nicht vorhanden und
ich hoffe dass wir ihre entscheidung auf
die drei kernkraftwerke in diesem winter
zu verzichten nicht bitter bereuen
müssen noch wäre zeit daher bitte
überdenken sie diese entscheidung
thomas gebhart war das für die
unionsfraktion
und ihm folgt jetzt für die
sozialdemokraten denkt bergt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen die bürgerinnen
bürger die wichtigste botschaft erstmal
vorweg im winter soll und wird niemand
in seiner wohnung frieren müssen die
ampel koalition und die bundesregierung
sind vorbereitet aber ich will nicht
drum herum reden die energieversorgung
in deutschland ist angespannt und die
lage ist ernst gerade heute wurde die
alarmstufe für gas aus berufen und der
grund ist offensichtlich putins gezielte
einsatz von energie als waffe das zwingt
uns zur abkehr von russland und jeder
der das anders sieht sollte wirklich mal
an seinem moralischen kompass arbeiten
meine damen und herren
die deutschen gasspeicher sie fühlen
sich derzeit bewegen sich die füllstände
etwa auf vorjahresniveau etwa 58 prozent
allerdings sind die gaslieferungen aus
russland ist im 1 deutlich gedrosselt
und dass es politisch motiviert und
natürlich müssen wir uns angesichts
dieser angespannten lage auf alle
eventualitäten vorbereiten und auch auf
den worst case da gebe ich ihnen recht
liebe kolleginnen kollegen von der union
aber genau das tun wir doch seit wochen
und monaten auch die alarmstufe ist ein
teil davon
für die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland haben wir bereits die
wichtigsten voraussetzungen geschaffen
wir haben die vorgeschriebene
mindesthöhe stände der gasspeicher die
zeitweise kontrolle des speichers in
rehden durch die bundesnetzagentur
ausbau der energieinfrastruktur an der
küste verträge mit alternativen
lieferanten auch in diesen wochen
schärfen wir aber an dieser stelle auch
nach für gas einsparungen und unsere
speicher zu füllen und vor allem für den
massiven ausbau erneuerbarer energie
über die beweggründe über die
beweggründe kann ich deshalb nur
mutmaßen entweder diebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der union sie waren in den
letzten wochen wohl selten anwesend oder
sie habe nicht richtig zugehört oder
aber das scheint mir leider am
wahrscheinlichsten sie wollen eine angst
schüren für einen kälte winter es gibt
sicher viel das ist in dieser situation
weiterhilft und da haben sie in den
vergangenen monaten auch sehr
konstruktiv mitgearbeitet dafür danken
wir ihnen aber angstmacherei gehört
nicht dazu meine damen und herren es
ist nicht die zeit in der es auf
aktionismus und schnittige interviews
ankommt sondern auch besonnenheit einen
klaren kompass und einen nachhaltigen
planung meine damen und herren und sie
herr merz und ihre fraktion wohl gerade
die rezepte des vergangenen jahrtausends
wieder aus der mottenkiste gegen jede
vernunft gemeint ist natürlich die
atomkraft die sie wieder die sie wieder
einsteigen wollen ich will nur mal kurz
daran erinnern das ist die technologie
mit den radioaktiven uran brennstäbe die
alles verstrahlen was in der nähe kommt
was ewig gelagert werden muss und wo die
lagerung in keiner richtung auftaucht
dafür zahlen wir alle und in deutschland
fallen bis 20 60 selbst nach dem
atomausstieg über 60.000 kubikmeter
radioaktiven mülls an und da sind man
eben 15.000 lkw ladungen voll teilt
dieses mülls plutonium 239 das ist das
radioaktive zeigt dass nach 24.000
jahren erst in die hälfte seiner atome
zerfallen ist und der rest braucht nur
12 bis 5000 jahre wissen sie meine
herrschaften was vor 5000 jahren war hat
die bronzezeit begonnen und die
pyramiden wurden gebaut nimmt so eine
zeitliche dimension wohin sie noch mehr
atommüll rein produzieren für dem wir
noch immer kein endlager haben meine
damen und herren sie merken
das ist alles nicht nachhaltig
atomkraftwerke zu reaktivieren das
wirtschaftlich schlicht nicht sinnvoll
rechtlich fragwürdig und mit erheblichen
sicherheitsrisiken verbunden und warum
sollten wir für ein wenig mehr
elektrische energie gerade war so um die
vier von 221 gigawatt deutlich höhere
risiken eingehen wenn wir doch wärme
brauchen auch die diskussion und
trekking in deutschland führt uns nicht
weiter für die gewinnung in deutschland
wäre massive investitionen nötig für
eine nicht nachhaltige und
umweltschädliche technologie und eine
erschließung braucht nicht nur geld
sondern die braucht auch zeit fünf jahre
bräuchten wir für eine förderrate die
gerade mal 20 prozent unseres bedarf
deckt deckt und das auch nur zehn jahre
lang das hilft uns auch nicht über den
winter ich mach mal folgenden vorschlag
wir setzen auf lösungen die realisierbar
sind nützlich zügig umsetzbar und vor
allem sicher
und dabei denken wir auch noch auf den
dreiklang zwischen energiesicherheit
energieersparnis und energiewende die
sicherheit gewähren wir durch die
mindest füllstände der gasspeicher und
parallel schaffen wir alternativen zu
putins gas bei und die lng terminals
noch weiter bis zu diesem winter aus die
energieersparnis generieren wir durch
informationen anreize und kommunikation
firmen werden nicht gebrauchtes gas
zurückgeben können und bürger bekommen
infos wie man ein staat das gesetz was
die kohlekraftwerke im notfall
reaktiviert liegt bereits auf dem tisch
und auch das macht gras frei für die
speicher und das dritte und wichtigste
von allem ist die energiewende solar
wind speichernetze innovations- anlagen
sind der schlüssel zur tür die uns aus
dieser fossilen energie krise
herausführt und dabei transformieren wir
die wirtschaft und ritten nebenbei noch
ein kleines bisschen dem planeten meine
damen und herren insofern ist mein fazit
recht eindeutig atomkraft gehört der
vergangenheit an denn sie brauchen wir
leider für den übergang tracking ist
unwirtschaftlich und den erneuerbaren
energien gehört die zukunft vielen dank
für
die verbliebenen atomkraftwerke in
deutschland die müssten nacht geltenden
atomrechts spätestens ende dezember vom
netz gehen vor dem mund hintergrund der
reduzierten gaslieferungen und dieser
debatte hier gibt es auch in der
koalition von seiten der fdp forderung
einer
laufzeitverlängerung zumindest zu prüfen
noch die zeit
und in der zwischenzeit erhält jetzt das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen der
abgeordnete bernard herrmann
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es freut mich liebe cdu/csu
dass ihr recht und ihre pflicht der
opposition wahrnehmen und diese aktuelle
stunde beantragt haben zu einem wahrlich
ernsten thema da werden wir uns schnell
einig dass wir über die versorgungslage
im kommenden winter nicht oft genug
debattieren können gerade vor dem
hintergrund aktueller entwicklungen noch
mehr hätte ich mich aber gefreut wenn
sie in den 16 jahren regierungszeit mit
gleichem eifer gehandelt hätten dann
wären wir heute beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren inzwischen spitzenreiter
und die heutige debatte wäre eine ganz
andere und jetzt fordern sie
planwirtschaft herbert auch noch den vbb
atom dass der staat einsteigt ist das
ihr ernst
heizkosten werden steigen weil
deutschland die energiewende verschlafen
hat und der ausbau der erneuerbaren
jahrelang ausgebremst oder unsere
abhängigkeit von fossilen energieträgern
haben wir eine politik des ausweichens
und blockieren zu verdanken deshalb
ernten wir heute was sie jahrelang gesät
haben wir grüne haben immer schon vor
dieser parteien abhängigkeit geworden
liest man
liest man den von ihm gewählten titel
der aktuellen stunde so könnte man
meinen sie hätten auch die letzten
monate schlafen seit beginn des ukraine
kriegs arbeiten herr beck und sein
ministerium mit hochdruck daran die
versorgung des der vergangener jahre
wieder geradezubiegen entschlossen und
zielgerichtet da kann man gar nicht
vorsorgen am heutigen tag zeigt sich
dass unsere mehr wir rufen die
alarmstufe aus weil wir schnell und
vorausschauend handeln
meine damen und herren frau präsidentin
ohne zweifel müssen wir die aufgabe die
uns ab sofort für den kommenden winter
bevorsteht gemeinsam und solidarisch als
gesellschaft bewältigen dahingehend
richtet sich auch der heutige appell des
wirtschaftsministers
den ich mit aller kraft unterstützen
damit uns dieser gemeinsam mit kraft gut
gelingt haben wir hier im bundestag
längst gesetz auf den weg gebracht und
bereiten weitere vor das oster und
sommer paket sind ja breit bekannt unser
kurs ist klar und lösungsorientiert wir
tun alles um die versorgungssicherheit
zu gewährleisten
ich möchte an dieser stelle erinnern vor
welche ausgangslage wir noch vor wenigen
monaten standen für die aktuelle
situation
bestanden keine vorausschauende
gesetzespaket es gab keine pläne in der
schublade
all das musste innerhalb weniger wochen
im akkordtempo aus dem boden gestampft
werden
das bundesministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz hat also sofort angepackt
und mit der diversifizierung unserer
energieversorgung losgelegt mit höchstem
tempo wird die versorgung mit
flüssigerdgas vorbereitet unsere
abhängigkeit von russland bei kohle und
öl ist beachtlich geschrumpft
wie im bundestag haben noch vor wenigen
wochen das gas speicher gesetz auf den
weg gebracht und auch wenn wir uns alle
einen anderen verlauf gewünscht hätten
wir haben gegenwärtig rechts instrumente
mit denen wir unverzüglich reagieren
konnten
zu langfristigen wahrung unserer
versorgungssicherheit gehört ohne wenn
und aber ein beschleunigter ausbau der
erneuerbaren dann müssen wir schleunigst
auf die tube drücken an der stelle liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von cdu csu
können sie uns tatkräftig unterstützen
damit wir unseren gemeinsamen zielen
endlich näher kommen
gleichzeitig wissen wir um die last und
die sorgen vieler menschen die nicht
warten können bis wir politisch alle
bögen geglättet haben
deshalb haben wir auch kurzfristig
gehandelt und mehrere entlastungspaket
und maßnahmen auf den weg gebracht
darunter den heizkostenzuschuss und die
energiepreis pauschale hohe
energiekosten betreffen auch den
täglichen arbeitsweg
dazu haben wir das 90 euro ticket
eingeführt und wir grüne werden die
erfahrungen mit der ticket nutzung ernst
nehmen und uns dafür einsetzen dass wir
längerfristige lösungen für eine
bezahlbare klimafreundliche mobilität
finden
und wir werden uns generell stark machen
für eine gerechtere lastenverteilung
zur gegenwärtigen wahrheit gehört das
aber auch unbequemes zu benennen wir
müssen sorgsam mit vorhandenen energie
umgehen
alles was wir jetzt und heute an energie
einsparen hilft unserer
versorgungssicherheit hilft uns allen
und hilft unserer industrie
und bringt uns gelassen über die
wintermonate deshalb begrüße ich jetzt
als fachpolitiker ausdrücklich dass das
bmw gemeinsam mit einem breiten bündnis
von verbänden zum energiesparen
aufgerufen hat jede und jeder kann und
soll damit machen ich würde mir wünschen
dass diese einfache möglichkeit des
mithelfen und die wirkungskraft dahinter
viel tiefer in unser aller bewusstsein
rückt und auch breiter in die
gesellschaft hinein und vor allem über
diejenigen hinaus die ohnehin schon
energiesparer samt sind oder bisher
schon sein mussten gerade für diese
menschen haben wir alle gemeinsam die
pflicht uns solidarisch zu verhalten
vielen dank
sagt ihr bernhard hermann für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen nächster
redner hier in dieser aktuellen stunde
wird sein der abgeordnete michael kruse
für die fdp fraktion deren
energiepolitischer sprecher
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst einmal
möchte ich sagen dass ich es sehr
angemessen findet dass diese debatte
jetzt in einem sehr ernsten ton fall
stattfindet und ich freue mich dass es
auf eine fraktion von der absatz aber
auch nicht erwartet alle anderen hier
dem ernst der lage danach angemessen
geworden sind auch in der art und weise
wie man mit regierungspolitik umgeht zur
realität gehört ja die lage in der wir
sind suchen wir uns jetzt nicht mehr aus
jemand anderes entscheidet darüber
wie schwer wiegen diese krise würde
jemand anderes entscheidet ob denn durch
bestimmte pipelines aus osten noch gas
zu uns fließt das heißt der rahmen der
ist längst gesetzt und herr spahn ich
kann es ihnen nicht ersparen diesen
rahmen haben die letzten beiden von
ihnen geführten regierungen gesetzt
diesen rahmen den haben sie zu
verantworten und was wir jetzt machen
von tag eins an dieser ampel regierung
ist hinter ihnen aufräumen und man muss
sich das wirklich man muss man muss sich
das wirklich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen also das ist als wenn sie in
einem clubabend randalieren und am
nächsten tag gehen sie hin und
beschimpften den aufgrund trupp das hat
keinen plan hat wie er denn nun aufgrund
wir machen hier wir machen wir
nachtschichten herr sparen wir machen
wir nachtschichten oder brechen unsere
gesetzesberatungen nur noch für aktuelle
stunden und debatten weil es hinter
ihrer politik so viel aufzuräumen gibt
und ich sage dass ich sage ich sage
ihnen dass sie können natürlich die
haben dann natürlich als opposition das
recht hier einen plan von uns
einzufordern würde ich auch tun würde
ich auch so ja selbstverständlich haben
wir beschlossen das gehört ja auch eine
ganze menge dazu
gehört ja eine ganze menge dazu dass
speichergesetz haben wir als allererstes
auf den weg gebracht zu diesem
speichergesetz möchte ich ihnen mal
einiges sagen der richtige zeitpunkt
dieses gesetz zu beschließen wäre
letztes jahr im juli gewesen letztes
jahr im juli als der
bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier hieß
letztes jahr im juli gab es die zahlen
dass gazprom in deutschland aus
speichert letztes jahr im juli hätte man
erkennen können dass hier ein
wirtschaftlicher angriff parallel zu
einem militärischen der vor der ukraine
vorbereitet wurde stattgefunden hat das
wäre der zeitpunkt gewesen zu erkennen
dass hier ein wirtschaftlicher krieg
gegen die deutschen interessen beginnt
und wenn sie sich jetzt hier hinstellen
und sagen wir müssten noch dinge anders
machen märz was beschlossen braucht ist
denn das noch nicht da dann kann ich
ihnen nur sagen erstens wir haben seit
märz eine reihe von gesetzen auf den weg
gebracht damit wir mit dieser krise
bestmöglich umgehen können und wir
räumen hinter ihnen auf genauso wie ich
es ihnen eben erklärte und was haben sie
uns eigentlich hinterlassen das betrifft
ja nicht nur die energiepolitik aber
auch was haben sie uns denn eigentlich
hinterlassen manchmal kurz sagen dass
100 milliarden programm damit unsere
bundeswehr wieder einsatzbereit ist das
haben wir beschlossen nach ihrer 16
jährigen regierungszeit wir räumen
hinter ihnen auch sie haben uns in der
energiepolitik in putins arme getrieben
wir räumen hinter ihnen auf und auch im
haushalt sieht es ja nicht besser unser
haushaltes jahr 20 milliarden besser als
der den sie noch geplant haben für
dieses jahr wir machen weniger schulden
als sie weil sie uns einen schuldensumpf
hinterlassen haben wir räumen hinter
ihrer politik auf lieber kollege sparen
und wenn sie dann einen plan von uns
einfach dann kann nur sagen speicher
gesetzt habe ich eben schon vorgetragen
energie sicherungs gesetz wir sorgen
dafür dass niemand die deutsche
kritische infrastruktur gegen unsere
interessen missbrauchen kann wo waren
sie eigentlich als die kritische
infrastruktur in hände von staaten
gelangt ist die nichts mit unseren
interessen gemein haben wo waren sie als
es darum ging zum richtigen zeitpunkt
entschied am netz umzusetzen ein grüner
wirtschaftsminister muss das erledigen
herr sparen weil sie ist in 16 jahren
nicht auf die kette kriegt habe ein
grüner wirtschaftsminister muss jetzt
sagen entschied im turbotempo ich räume
alle die die maßnahmen aus dem weg alle
die blockaden wir machen das maximale
tempo damit dass in diesem land gelingt
herr spahn ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen
aufgefallen ist aber das ist teil
unseres plans um dieses land aus der
krise zu führen im gartenbereich in die
sie dieses land geführt habe
ist der plan ist bahn
und dann sind wir ja auch gerade dran
erneuerbare energien eeg wind an
landwind auf see und weitere gesetzliche
verhandeln die gerade alle parallel herr
sparen ich habe in meinem ersten halben
jahr im deutschen bundestag mehr gute
gesetze auf den weg gebracht als sie in
ihrer ganzen zeit als
gesundheitsminister zum thema krone
und natürlich gibt es noch viele weitere
maßnahmen die wir ergreifen werden im
gasbereich etwa die eigene nordsee
förderung dazu kommen wir dann separat
ich kann ihnen sagen wir warten nicht
auf den nächsten märz und hoffen dass
der uns aus der krise führt sondern
behandeln damit dieses land nicht so
weit in die krise reinkommt wie sie zu
verantworten gehabt hätten vielen dank
michael kruse von der fdp der sich hier
noch mal an der rede von jens spahn
abgearbeitet hat die es ja hier zum
auftakt dieser aktuellen stunde gab die
sich noch melden ab und zu in der
aktuellen stunde gibt es keine
zwischenfragen also ist jetzt nicht böse
von mir sondern die werden einfach
grundsätzlich nicht zugelassen
ich muss sie trotzdem noch einen
augenblick warten lassen denn ich muss
ja noch einmal fragen ist noch irgendein
mitglied hier was an der abstimmung
nicht teilgenommen hat bisher das sie
ich nicht dann schließt sich jetzt die
abstimmung und bitte die schriftführerin
und schriftführer mit der auszählung zu
beginnen und das ergebnis wird ihnen
dann später bekanntgegeben der und hier
im hintergrund beziehungsweise hier im
flur auf dem westflügel des reichstages
der leaf jetzt in der vergangenen stunde
eine namentliche abstimmungen zwar ging
es darum ein mitglied des pkgr des
sogenannten parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums zu wählen das ist jenes
gremium dass die geheimdienste
kontrolliert hier hat die afg keinen
vertreter oder eine vertreterin bisher
entsendet weil kein afg abgeordneter
gewählt worden ist mit der
erforderlichen mehrheit heute ist der
abgeordnete der afc martin hess dazu
noch einmal angetreten wir haben es ja
gehört das muss jetzt erst mal
ausgezählt werden
situation natürlich ernst die eskalation
von putin der die gaslieferungen letzten
endes nochmal einseitig einschränkt
bringt uns in eine noch schwierigere
situation und die bundesregierung hat
die alarmstufe 2 des notfallplans
ausgerufene richtigerweise
ausgerufen diese maßnahme ist sogar
überfällig wenn man sich die situation
bei lichte betrachtet und wir müssen als
land aber natürlich auch als
gesellschaft zusammen rücken auch
zusammenstehen das heißt natürlich auch
dass wir gerade jetzt sämtliche gas
potenziale verstärkt zum einen ersetzen
müssen durch andere lieferanten
natürlich auch durch erneuerbare wir
müssen gas potenziale aber auch
erschließen wir müssen andere ressourcen
0 und wir müssen auch einsparen das ist
überhaupt keine frage durch anreize aber
auch durch belohnungen und wir verlangen
in der tat seiten jetzt einen plan wie
das russische gas ersetzt wird die
regierung hat diesen plan auch
zugesichert und das muss man dann schon
auch aushalten denn wir darauf hinweisen
dass dieser plan eben noch nicht
vorliegt liebe damen und herren und die
bundesregierung handelt in der tat sehr
zaghaft es ist viel zeit verstrichen wir
müssen die menschen wir müssen aber auch
die wirtschaft schützen vor mangel und
vor not gehen denn genau das droht in
zukunft und der bundesminister habig hat
ja recht wenn er sagt es gehe um die die
kilowattstunde um so unverständlicher
ist es übrigens das im märz noch der
block a des kohlekraftwerks neurath mit
300 megawatt von ihnen vom netz genommen
wurde allein mit diesem blog hätten sie
eine zehnte des monatlich verstummten
gases einsparen können und keiner kann
alles wissen und alles richtig machen
aber das war eben nicht richtig zur
damaligen zeit und darauf weisen wir
entsprechend auch hin um so
unverständlicher ist es übrigens auch
dass der begrenzte begrenzte
weiterbetrieb der noch laufenden akw s
nicht ernsthaft aus tableau kommt und da
geht es nicht um neue atomkraftwerke wie
die afg des beispielsweise fordert es
geht auch nicht darum dass unmengen an
mehr brennstäben letzten endes
endgelagert werden müssen es geht darum
dass die drei verbliebenen
kernkraftwerke immerhin mit einer
nennleistung von 4,3 gigawatt ein
drittel des verströmten gases einsparen
könnten allein das kernkraftwerk isar 2
produziert so viel strom wie alle gas
kraftwerke in bayern ganz ähnlich in
neckarwestheim in baden württemberg und
wir müssen ja natürlich auch wenn es um
netzstabilität und versorgungssicherheit
geht die regionalen besonderheiten
entsprechend auch berücksichtigen und es
ist doch schlicht nicht glaubhaft dass
die reaktoren die im dezember noch
sicher laufen können und werden im
januar und im februar neben jetzt nicht
mehr können deshalb fordern wir eine
ideologie lose prüfung eines
weiterbetriebs wie das ja auch teile der
fdp tun
[Applaus]
in deutschland wurde im mai zu viel gas
verströmt wie noch nie nämlich und 4
terawattstunden das ist doch wahnsinn in
der jetzigen situation wir laufen in
eine gasmenge lage und verstromen
gleichzeitig gas das wir gar nicht
verstromen müssten im moment ist es
nicht dass entweder kohlekraftwerk oder
atomkraftwerk einschalten oder eben
entsprechende reaktivieren wir brauchen
ein sowohl als auch und sie handeln hier
einfach zu spät und machen zu wenig und
sind auch zu unentschlossen bei der tat
weite der schwierigkeiten denen wir uns
gegenüber ausgesetzt sind
wir müssen jetzt wirklich alle
kapazitäten nutzen wie gesagt die
laufzeiten der akw verlängern die
kohlekraftwerke nutzen alle erneuerbaren
nutzen natürlich massiv ausbauen aber
auch die biomasse nutzen und da hören
wir nicht mehr als ankündigungspolitik
viele dieser anlagen werden in der lage
kurzfristig ihre strom der mir aber auch
gas produktion signifikant zu erhöhen
und damit auch die gasspeicher
entsprechend zu schonen sie haben es in
der hand mit vergleichsweise leicht
umzusetzen den regulatorischen
anpassungen dieses potenzial auch zu
heben sie schalten an dessen im oster
paket die wasserkraft absolut
inkonsequent das potenzial der
geothermie und sie zeigen kann den
fahrplan auf den brauchen wir aber weil
die nächsten wochen und die nächsten
monate nicht leicht werden wie gesagt
ein spanier setzen erschließen
natürlich auch letzten endes auf etwa
etwaigen situationen reagieren wir sind
gerne gesprächsbereit wenn es um
lösungen geht bitten sie aber auch ihrer
verantwortung entsprechend nachzukommen
herzlichen dank
als nächstes erhält timon gremmels das
wort für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das überlegen
wir uns mal wir hätten im märz auf den
märz gehört im märz am leuten dritten
hat friedrich merz
der presse gesagt nach den ausbau nach
dem aus der ostseepipeline nord stream
zwei fordert die cdu csu im bundestag
auch den stopp von nord stream 21 diese
einschränkungen in der gasversorgung
werden hart aber akzeptabel zitat
friedrich merz wir sind der meinung dass
wir das akzeptieren müssen ein gesicht
der lage die dort entstanden ist sie
haben im märz geforderten norm 2 vom
netz nehmen was wäre denn dann fast
schon trotzdem 1 vom netz zu nehmen was
wäre denn dann passiert wir hätten
erstens unsere speicher die filme können
zweitens wäre es richtig teuer geworden
für die verbraucher und drittens wäre es
auch so dass wir dann insgesamt weniger
gas zur verfügung haben wo sich jetzt
hier hingestellt und so eine aktuelle
stunde zu machen kann man machen aber
muss auch die eigene politische
verantwortung weil hier adressieren
meine sehr verehrten damit hätten wir
auch die schädigung gehörte these gehört
hätten wir nord stream 1 abgeschaltet
hätten wir heute eine ganz andere
situation deswegen sind ihre kontakte
deals tränen die sie ihr heulen
heuchlerisch mehrwerten damen und herren
natürlich haben die show unterfordert
können sie gerne nachlesen aber wenn sie
sich von ihrem eigenen
fraktionsvorsitzenden
distanzieren sehr geehrter sparen ist
das auch nur nachricht wert also sie
sagen sie hätten das nie gefordert dann
lesen sie bitte nach friedrich merz
gesagt hat meine sehr verehrten und dann
kommen sie und fordern wir alternativ
kann man machen sie sagen aber auf
einmal die atomkraft selbst sagen die
alternative ich habe das gefühl dass
manch einer in der union einfach nur
lange darauf gewartet hat diese alten
konzepte aus der schublade rauszuholen
und nach dem motto 'jetzt ist kriegt
jetzt können wieder alles mögliche
fordern kommen diese alten konzepte
wieder auf den tisch und das ist meine
damen und herren nicht die richtige
antwort gucken sie doch mal wenn wir es
jetzt verlängern würden wo kommen denn
die brennelemente her die hälfte der
brennelemente kommen aus russland das
wäre sozusagen den teufel mit dem
beelzebub auszutreiben wenn wir an
dieser stelle jetzt sozusagen statt gas
aus russland atombrennstäbe aus russland
uhren würden das ist die politik der
union meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und natürlich ist es doch so
gucke mir meiner frankreich die atom
republik die da ist was macht denn die
franzosen 56 atomkraftwerke haben sie
laufen viele sind stillgelegt weil die
in wartung sind beziehungsweise war es
so warm ist und die flüsse gar nicht
mehr kühlen können das ist doch der
punkt wir haben im mai liter sparen wir
haben im mai strom nach frankreich
exportiert war die atomkraft nicht
verstanden nicht funktioniert hat meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass in frankreich
die lichter nicht ausgeht und sie sagen
die antwort ist dass wir auch mehr atom
setzen müssen dass da wirklich zu viel
zu kurz gesprungen was sie hier fordern
meine sehr verehrten damen und
deswegen kann die antwort nur sein und
ich bin robert habeck und der
bundesregierung sehr dankbar dass wir
jetzt hier genau handeln weil wir müssen
doch aufpassen dass wenn nord 10.1 jetzt
in revision geht in die geplante
revision geht die dauert in der regel um
die zehn tage die große gefahr ist doch
dass es danach nicht wieder hochgefahren
wird und es wäre doch im wahrsten sinn
des wortes busses russisches roulette
wenn wir uns sozusagen darauf verlassen
wir müssen jetzt die frau vorgetragen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
dass wir dann er werden können und uns
da nicht von putin an der nase
herumführen lassen deswegen ist die
politik der bundesregierung der richtige
weg um uns hier voran zu bringen und wir
müssen viel mehr auf erneuerbare
energien setzen oder höre ich immer sehr
schön dass die union das jetzt auch
fordert mal so wir werden ihn ende der
nächsten sitzungswoche die gelegenheit
geben sozusagen ihren worten auch taten
folgen zu lassen dann werden wir ganze
reihe von gesetzen des oster paketes
hier auf den weg bringen und ich werde
sehr genau und wir werden sehr genau
achten ob das was sie jetzt hier
verkünden ihre erkenntnisgewinne dass
sie jetzt auf einmal in den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien sind dass sie
gehen dann bitteschön auch taten folgen
lassen wir werden sie daran messen dass
sie dann auch hoffentlich sehen gesetzen
da haben wir koalition auch unterstützen
und auch zustimmen werden daran werden
wir sie messen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
hier tun für den winter einiges wir
werden hier auch die versäumnisse der
letzten cdu geführten regierung
aufräumen ist war doch ihre minister der
anlage blockiert hat sie zu noch immer
so als ob sie mit dem letzten 16 jahren
nichts zu tun hätten wer war denn ihr
wirtschaftsminister das war meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren sehen können
sie sich ja dieser stelle überhaupt
nicht wegducken wir holen das nach was
sie versäumt haben und dafür tragen sie
auch die verantwortung wir fühlen uns in
dieser bundesregierung gewappnet wir
sind gut und geben den menschen auch ein
signal dass wir ihre ängste und sorgen
ernst nehmen auch die industrie und auch
das hier in deutschland am ende des
tages und ende des jahres kassiert dafür
setzen wir die voraussetzung ist für tat
es wird nicht einfach aber wir tun alles
dafür dass die menschen hier auch in
sicherheit und in wärme leben können wir
sehr vertrauen unter vielen dank
sobald timon gremmels für die spd
fraktion so ein redner haben wir noch in
dieser aktuellen stunde das wird sein
stefan wenzel für bündnis 90 die grünen
erst der sprecher für umwelt und
naturschutz seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich bin
froh dass wir in dieser lage eine
bundesregierung haben die handelt die
sich sehr bewusst den herausforderungen
stellt die sich nach dem angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine im februar dieses jahres
stellen drei maßnahmen notfallvorsorge
und
ersparen dafür wurden jetzt auch im
vorfeld die gesetzlichen voraussetzungen
geschaffen um prioritäten zu klären um
erst mal zu gucken wo sind eigentlich
die verbräuche um das auch entsprechend
administrieren zu können
und dabei wurden auch sehr unbequeme
entscheidungen getroffen lg nutzung der
netze reserve auch das sind maßnahmen
die jetzt eingeleitet wurden in den
letzten wochen und dann das thema
effizienz und einsparung von elementarer
bedeutung auch weil es um preisdämpfer
umgeht auch weil diese maßnahmen zur
preissenkung führen im industriebereich
im bereich der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher hilft uns das einerseits
jetzt zu dämpfen bei der nachfrage und
andererseits dafür zu sorgen dass die
rechnungen kleiner werden und natürlich
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
ganz entscheidend da kommen die gesetze
mein kollege darauf hingewiesen zum
größten teil in zwei wochen hier auf den
tisch und so kam mir wo kommen wir her
ersparen sie haben gesagt das ging hier
alles nicht schnell genug im letzten
jahr um diese zeit die ganzen sommer
über bis zum herbst bis zur
regierungsübernahme haben sie noch nicht
mal gemerkt dass der größte gasspeicher
in deutschland schlicht und einfach fast
leerer bora
bora die regierung mit dem
wirtschaftsminister altmaier warum haben
wir nicht einmal gehört wie die
situation ist meine damen und herren in
den letzten drei jahren ihrer
regierungszeit ist der windkraftausbau
um 90 prozent eingebrochen meine damen
und herren und das ist wirklich eine
ganz heftige zahl meine damen und herren
wir wären schon längst viel unabhängiger
und vor allen dingen werden auch die
industrie im land gehalten die
arbeitsplätze die hier verloren gegangen
sind die hätten wir gehalten meine damen
und herren und ich muss auch noch
manchmal denken an die letzten ausstieg
aus dem ausstieg herr sparen
2010 war dass diese entscheidung die hat
uns am ende milliarden gekostet die sie
auch mit zu verantworten haben und meine
damen und herren klar ist wir haben ein
gas problem wir haben ein gas problem
und das spüren die firmen und das spüren
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
nicht erst im winter sondern bereits
jetzt
wir haben
im moment einen gaspreis etwa 130 euro
pro megawattstunde am groß waren
großhandel im letzten jahr hat basf
wahrscheinlich noch für den preis von
1520 euro eingekauft so da gibt es noch
altverträge einige haben möglicherweise
noch die kostengünstigen bezugsquellen
aber alle die die am spot markt
einkaufen müssen die zahlen die hohen
preise und die haben die probleme
natürlich schon heute und deswegen geht
es jetzt auch darum wie können wir
unsere industrie für die zukunft
wettbewerbsfähig machen wie sorgen wir
dafür dass die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher zu vertretbaren preisen ihre
wohnung auch
beheizen können und dann spielt eine
ganz enorme rolle dass er jetzt
vorausschauend in die technik ihnen
gehen die uns dabei der zukunft helfen
und der blick nach frankreich zeigt dass
der weg dort nicht der richtige ist in
den ganzen letzten drei vier monaten des
letzten jahres hatte frankreich durchweg
deutlich höhere strompreise
beispielsweise als wir hier in
mitteleuropa und jetzt sehen wir das im
moment auch wieder
atomkraft ersparen hat sich als
preistreiber erwiesen und auch das
einzige atomkraftwerk was derzeit neu
gebaut wird dort ist mittlerweile zehn
jahre im verzug
kosten ursprünglich 35 milliarden jetzt
ist man bei 19 5 milliarden meine damen
und herren wenn wir wettbewerbsfähige
preise wollen geht das anders und wir
dürfen uns auch nicht wieder in neue
abhängigkeiten bringen selbst die ura
die usa haben 25 prozent ihrer
brennelemente aus russischen quellen
bezogen wir dürfen nicht wieder in diese
abhängigkeit hinein 18 kraftwerke
nukleare kraftwerke in osteuropa hänge
noch von russischen quellen ab und für
53 prozent der welt uranvorkommen kommen
aus usbekistan kasachstan und russland
ist diese zeit lassen wir hoffentlich
bald hinter uns ersparen aber trotzdem
habe ich die hoffnung dass wir die
entscheidenden fragen die entscheidenden
weichenstellungen für die zukunft auch
hier mit möglichst breiten mehrheiten
zählen können weil es das weil das bei
solchen sie bitte zum großen
herausforderungen immer gut ist wenn
auch eine große herausforderung
stellt vielen dank fürs zuhören der
verletzer redner hier in dieser
aktuellen stunde wir haben ein gas
problem hat er gesagt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat gesagt wir
haben eine gaskrise in deutschland auch
wenn im moment die versorgungssicherheit
noch gewährleistet sei aber diese
aktuelle stunde die schon vorher
beantragt war übrigens von der union die
ist heute morgen sozusagen noch mal von
aktuellen geschehnissen eingeholt worden
denn der bundeswirtschaftsminister hat
er die zweite eskalationsstufe des
notfallplans gas ausgerufen diese
alarmstufe soll ein deutliches signal an
industrien verbraucher setzen der
gasverbrauch muss sinken
mangel im herbst und winter zu
verhindern und die maßnahmen der früh
waren stücke werden also in dieser
alarmstufe noch
intensiviert aktive markteingriffe sind
in diese alarmstufe allerdings noch
nicht vorgesehen